hey you know what we haven't heard from
in a while let's go to bobo the guy's
been on the phone for
three hours uh i can't believe yesterday
nobody brought up the fact that bruce
took a drink from a stranger
you don't know what was in that drink
not to mention covert right
i think the weird part of the story is
that bruce gets off his motorcycle when
he sees a bunch of fans and like wants
to hang out with him i mean
that was weird to me these guys who ride
motorcycles
like people for some reason other they
won't get in a car
and ride with people but they'll ride on
their motorcycles with people
you know who's a big motorcycle guys
like fred
fred whenever fred never is around
people
but he'll ride with people yeah yeah
he's always like yeah i'm on my
motorcycle not true
i love it i'm a solo rider i'm not one
of those guys that rides in the pack i
i despise that it's like i want to be
with my own thoughts
i actually try to get better with my
motorcycle skills so i'll take it in
into like where there are like a lot of
winding turns and things like that look
you
paint that's the way that you relax
riding a motorcycle is the way that i
relax
do you set up an obstacle course you can
go around cones
no i do not rob
there's this skill set yeah i remember
freight because you're going this
triumph motorcycle
i hung out with him you did like a a
bikers for babies run right fred
fred you hung out with bobo on a biker
for babies run
you like like you hung out with bobo
when uh when your daughter was born
in other words you were doing something
you were doing something in bobo showed
up
and he sort of stalked me so we weren't
hanging out
bobo just kind of we hung out when you
used to play out behind we walked to
7-eleven together
you hung out again again i was out
playing somewhere and you stalked me
and it was nice to see you bob i'm glad
you came and i'm you know it was it was
fun
i'm a fan of youtube bobo especially
when you crash into trucks with your
cougar
very good thank you the fascinating
conversation but
no a defensive ronnie yesterday i'm
calling for the unfoul
apples movement okay nobody cares yes
wait wait i have a question howard do
you think
that the captain of the titanic quiet
after he hit the iceberg your thoughts
yeah
[Music]
yeah you really do confuse me